I feel like you live a crazy life man no
did I grew up really in the you know
there weren't a lot of diseases I did a
I did uh I did a fundraiser last night I
was at a fundraiser from lymphoma right
and I've never even heard of it
comedy fundraiser yellow foam in
leukemia you know and I never even heard
of lymphoma you know in no offense if
anybody has lymphoma but I had like I
grew up around rabies was like the
hottest thing he did maybe think good a
rabies get bit by a squirrel or some
[ __ ] where from
yeah keuner that's from yeah there's a
lot of animal Stuart or cousin anybody
that's uh you know not taking good care
of themselves and they spend a lot of
time outdoors and you can to dead
giveaways that people have rabies are if
they're afraid to drink water and if
they're kind of playing hide-and-go-seek
by themselves a little bit like if you
see them yeah except them and that's
that's rabies rabies
you don't know beat it many times you
die yeah and you can look that up dude I
don't know what actually you can Bobby
just close your eyes and no you know and
now they work that's the dark arts boy
hey wait
I feel like rabies is a problem Oh in
the South though I liked up to say now
in the South I think NASCAR rabies
rednecks you know oh no Tony Stewart
poster
Jeff Gordon - head - yeah I think so
Danica Patrick brazier on fried food
mascot and rabies is the south man that
I tour in the south so I'm prey killing
my ticket sales but you know I'm saying
like rabies in LA is not a big issue no
it's not a big issue I think people
don't spend enough time with real ass
animals a lot of these animals out here
[ __ ] trained imports
fake guys little Dalmatians and [ __ ]
some gay man to live out of park by me
used to put spots on his own [ __ ] get
it together brother why would the guy
put I don't know I don't know that man
I'm gonna go by people like that if some
new spot in his own petrol I'm out it's
not like Dalmatians are rare or some
[ __ ] I get if you have a pet where I
don't wanna paint them white and get one
left but with [ __ ] Dalmatians
painting talks is insane
yeah that's people in parks man people
do anything in a park out here you got a
notice that out here like where I'm from
a park is a place to picnic you know
Micheline yeah chill out make art or
something but frisbee yeah I hear it's a
lot of drug scene drug people living out
there yeah well gang activity lot but
sex yeah Johnson that's a bit you know
people out there getting that Magic
Johnson is one of his favorite players
then even gettin a it's from a dude is
crime what another dude gift you know II
don't know home first to write a letter
to them
the mail that hope he gets better since
I'm [ __ ] fan mail [ __ ] up my afternoon
is right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]